ce n'est pas contre berck que trappe
pour a lancé sa saison par une victoire
mené 47 22 à la fin du second quart
temps presqu'à la dérive face aux
joueurs nordistes les trappistes se
diriger vers une seconde défaite
consécutive en championnat
c'est alors qu'un groupe de jeunes
visiblement supporters du psg se saisit
d'un extincteur et s'en sert dans les
tribunes les salariés du club auront
beau tenter de nettoyer le parquet en
vain les arbitres décident de suspendre
la rencontre de nettoyer toute la
surface
la surface du terrain donc ils ont jugé
que la surface était dangereuse et puis
donc il y avait quand même la poudre au
haut niveau
un dossier disciplinaire devrait être
ouvert par la fédération
le sct risque une amende voire même une
suspension de terrain en plus évidemment
de la défaite face à berck le club de
trappes devrait porter plainte